[Music]
hands put your empty hands in
my and scars show me all the scars you
hide and hey if your wings are broken
please take mine till yours can open to
cuz I'm going to stand by you
oh tears make a lot of sculps In Your
Eyes it hurt I know you Hur
my and love if your wings are
broken yours can open to cuz I'm going
to stand by you even if we Brak it down
we can find a way to break through even
if I can't find Heaven I walk through
hell with you love you're not alone cuz
I'm going to stand by you even if I
can't find heaven I'm going to stand by
you even if I can't find Heaven I walk
through hell with you love you're not
alone cuz I'm going to stand by you yeah
you're all I never knew I need
it in the heart sometimes it's unclear
why it's
spe and love if your rngs are broken we
can breath through those emotions too
cuz I'm going to stand by
you all truth I guess truth is what you
believe
in and faith I think faith is heav
reason and I not not love if your rings
are broken B my can open so cuz I'm
going to stand by you even if bring it
down we can find a way to break through
even if we can't find Heaven a walk
through hell with you love you're not
alone cuz I'm going to stand by you even
if we can't find heaven I'm going to
stand by you even if I can't find Heaven
I walk through hell with you love you're
not alone cuz I'm going to stand by you
I'll be your eyes till you can't shine
and I'll be your arms I'll be your
steady sat
light when you can't
rise well I'll cry with you on hands and
KNE by you even if we're breaking down
we can find a way to break through even
if we can't find Heaven I walk through
hell with you love you're not alone cuz
I'm going to stand by you even if we
can't find Heaven I want stand by you
even if we can't find Heaven walk
through hell with
you you're not alone cuz I'm going to
stand by you love you're not
alone stand by you
I'm going to stand by
you hey there friends so Mufasa did that
amazing camera work for me there say hi
to the people Mufasa hi people excellent
uh Mufasa is a pretty awesome flow
artist in his own right and you should
go check him out where can they find you
youall can find me at F Mona on
Instagram and YouTube outstanding sir
thank you so much for the help he thank
you
man hey friends I hope you enjoyed that
flow session of that marvelous song by
Rachel platen um if you'd like to grab a
set of the orb POI Pro LED contact poy
that I was using in this video uh you
can do so and get 10% off your purchase
when you use the code Drex factor with a
zero instead instead of an O at checkout
over at Ultra po.com once again that is
drexfactor with a zero instead of an o
thank you so much to ultra poy for
sponsoring this video and giving me an
excuse to go show off their awesome sets
of LED poy and speaking of thank yous uh
I also owe thanks to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys pyro terly
toys and Ultra poy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible uh
you can learn more about all these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
that I've got down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- business friend of the channel That
is Becca Becken thank you so very much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission and final thanks go out to the
people that make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible which is
my patreon supporters and in particular
I'd love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now thank you so much you all rock and
if you out there are not currently
supporter but enjoy the videos that I
create there's an easy way to be able to
make sure that more of them happen and
that's to go sign up for my patreon over
at
patreon.com Factor po there you can get
access to a whole host of amazing
rewards but better than that you'll be
uh helping me out in my mission to bring
pois spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and if after all that
you're hungry to see me flow more uh
I've got a playlist of past flow videos
I've done that I will go ahead and link
to down in the description as well as up
on screen thank you so much for watching
and I hope you were inspired to go out
and flow yourselves today I'll see you
in the new video real soon take care and
peace